Харків дуже сміливий.
І сміливість тих рішень-експериментів
дуже сильно сформував вигляд міста.
Найяскравішими насправді є оці кольори.
Такі червоні, помаранчеві та білий.
Є «Держпром» зі своїм таким бетоном і оці райони ХТЗ.
Простір, який немає меж.
Забудований масовим житлом.
За таким поширеним міфом у історії архітектури,
Харків виглядає як місто,
яке збудоване тільки за часів радянської влади.
І що наша індустріальна потужність також була
спадком саме радянського періоду.
Але це зовсім не так.
Тому що дійсно Харків був, напевне, найбільшим індустріальним
центром Сходу України ще 1867–1870 років.
Це почалося насамперед через видобуток вугілля і руди на Донбасі.
Харків був свого роду воротами Донбасу.
Тобто тут осідали фінанси, тут осідали гроші,
тут осідали власне ті промисловці, вони також жили тут.
Це будинок культури «Металіст».
Він був побудований у 1909 році, за проєктом архітектора Загоскіна.
Це пам’ятка місцевого значення.
Ось там ви бачите дві таблички,
що це повинно охоронятися законом України.
Але яким чином цей закон імплементується...
Насправді підзаконних актів як таких немає
або вони суперечать один одному.
Тому це дає можливість для того,
щоб пам’ятки взагалі не реставрувалися.
Треба якось приділяти увагу саме культурній інфраструктурі.
Не у центрі міста, а як тут, десь на околицях.
Тому що це об’єкт, який має бібліотеку, дитячі гуртки.
І це важливий інфраструктурний і соціальний об’єкт.
Він може привертати увагу, тут можуть розвиватися громади,
він може бути центром для громад.
[російською] Архітектура обслуговувала найрізноманітніші ідеї.
[російською] Насамперед це місто індустрії, місто хай-тека.
[російською] Є низка певних маркувальних об'єктів, дуже важливих.
[російською] А, власне, просторово історична
частина міста є пейзажною.
[російською] Це «місто п'яти пагорбів»,
[російською] і взаємини між цими пагорбами,
звичайно, дуже тонкі.
[російською] У Москалівці є такі напівміські-напівсільські простори,
[російською] які знаходяться безпосередньо біля центру.
[російською] Також такий феномен — [англійською] суперсело,
[російською] який можна було б якось культивувати та оберігати.
Ми приїхали на Москалівку.
Це такий район, який забудовувався
з розвитком Харкова, з розвитком міста.
Він почав розбудовуватися в середині 19 століття.
Тут багато людей просто живе поколіннями.
І я, наприклад, знаю практично всіх своїх сусідів.
Це не просто люди, які в'їхали,
а це люди, які прожили тут з дитинства і досі живуть.
Тут прожили і наші батьки, і також дружили.
Зараз ми практично в центрі цього району.
Ми бачимо, що тут збереглася така бруківка.
Позаду — перша бібліотека міста Харкова.
Вона зараз проходить такий етап, втрачає свою автентичність.
Це місце, яке трохи...
Ще кілька років тому нагадувало про...
От те відчуття цього району, яке було.
Зміни торкаються цього району, зміни торкаються міста.
І ми бачимо, що цінність міської ідентичності втрачається.
Сюди поселяли москалів, солдатів.
Іноді цей район називали Аравія.
Тому що тут дуже сипуча поверхня і тут не можна будувати високі будівлі.
Тому дуже класно зберігається усе.
Тут також доволі відоме місце — будинок Кричевського.
Це відомий український архітектор, художник.
Він створював малий герб України.
Багато тут збереглося цегли, харківської цегли.
Останні років 5 її стало набагато менше,
тому що хтось пофарбував будівлю, хтось облицював.
Але оці кольори, які були традиційні для Харкова, — найяскравіші.
На сьогодні збереглася структура кварталів.
Це нарізка, квартальна нарізка, по 6 соток.
І тут унікальним є те, що всі будівлі виходять на вулицю.
І це такий немов формат українських таунхаусів.
Кожен дім мав парадний вхід з вулиці.
І за часів Радянського Союзу, коли всі закривалися, ці двері закрились.
[російською] Мені не подобається слово «стиль».
[російською] Правильна тенденція — це певний критичний регіоналізм.
[російською] І він пов'язаний з тим, що наш клімат доволі унікальний.
[російською] Коли архітектура реагує на такий важливий компонент,
[російською] пов'язаний із сонцем, вітром, опадами, снігами.
[російською] Другий момент пов'язаний з традиціями,
[російською] культурою, виробництвом будівельних матеріалів тощо.
[російською] Зазвичай він пов'язаний з ресурсами,
які знаходяться безпосередньо тут.
[російською] Наприклад, Харків — місто крутих червоних глин.
Червона цегла — це щось, що ми повинні оберігати,
як саме приклад ідентичності чи характеру саме Харкова.
Чи тієї мови, якою Харків розмовляє.
До того ж вона гарна, вона така готична.
З цього можна стільки всього зробити для сучасних архітекторів.
Це можна трактувати, надихатися цим.
Ще мені подобається ХТЗ.
ХТЗ — це моя любов з першого і, напевно, до останнього погляду.
Ще це цікаво через те, що тракторний завод і Тракторобуд
пов’язані, зокрема, із слідом американців тут.
Тому що саме завод будувався за проєктом майстерні Кана.
Це архітектор Генрі Форда та архітектор Детройта.
Житловий комплекс поряд — це 4 квартали дуже цікавої експериментальної забудови.
Все мало бути сполучено переходами.
І що ще цікаво: саме влада була проти і ці переходи обрізали.
Через те що це щось про більш абстрактну ідею.
Ідею поєднання архітектури і суспільства разом, в одну структуру.
Ми всі пов’язуємо один одного горизонталлю.
Інша тема про горизонталь, звичайно, це Держпром.
Тому що переходи Держпрому надихнули велику кількість,
знову ж таки, британських бруталістів на їхні об’єкти,
які зараз дуже відомі, і всі їздять дивитися британський бруталізм.
Але я можу сказати, що Харківський Держпром — це Мекка
для всіх, хто вивчає модерністичну архітектуру.
Я бачила двох людей, які обіймали Держпром.
А одного, який цілував.
Це дійсно неймовірна споруда.
Вона сучасна, новаторська.
І інше питання, яке, певно, зі спадщиною, пам’яттю пов’язано,
може, ви бачили, що там така сталінська архітектура всюди.
Воно не сталінське.
Тобто це декорування після Другої світової війни.
Знаєте, як єгипетські фараони, вони знищували всю пам’ять про попередників.
Так само це сталінське декорування знищувало
пам’ять про харківський НЕП, Скрипника тощо.
За всіма цими будівлями стоять історії людей.
Історії і архітекторів, і тих, хто брав участь у будівництві,
і тих, хто користується ними зараз.
Ця спадщина архітектури конструктивізму дуже впливає.
І на те, як думають харківські архітектори, як вони розуміють,
знову ж таки, архітектурний метод.
Це насамперед зазвичай функціоналісти.
Саме у цьому будинку жили всі письменники та поети, можна сказати, українського відродження.
Це був осередок, де вони майже брали участь у проєктуванні і будуванні.
Тому що це був пайовий будинок, тобто вони самі платили внесок на момент будівництва і проєктування.
Це їхній будинок, це не держава їм збудувала, це вони самі собі збудували.
І це, в принципі, феномен будь-яких корпоративних будинків.
Архітектура — це архітектор Дашкевич.
Ми не можемо сказати, що це винятково конструктивізм.
Тобто такий модерністичний рух, простий.
Там є елементи, які схожі чимось на стилізовані колони,
є центрична композиція.
І тому я вважаю, що це швидше артдеко, ніж чистий конструктивізм.
[російською] Тут насправді багато великого відбувалося.
[російською] І актори театру «Березіль»,
[російською] і ті хто якимось чином були пов'язані
з архітектурою, мистецтвом, дизайном.
[російською] Тобто це все були одні компанії.
[російською] Тут була їдальня, ось на першому поверсі.
[російською] Потім був дитячий центр.
[російською] І солярій на верхньому рівні — місця, де вони засмагали.
[російською] Але насправді за способом життя,
вони безкінечно ходили з їжею,
[російською] пляшками та розмовами одне до одного.
[російською] Це був такий безперервний процес.
[російською] Це суперуспішна соціальна кооперація, взаємодія, спілкування,
[російською] яка дало за короткий час таку кількість
великої літератури, мистецтва, театру!
[російською] Воно було пов'язано з інтенсивністю передачі знань,
[російською] спілкуванням, обміном думками, батлами.
[російською] Початок 20 століття — це не час одинаків.
[російською] Це час різноманітних творчих угрупувань, досить неформальних.
[російською] Але після виходу Сталінського маніфесту — статті в газеті «Правда» про соціалістичний реалізм,
[російською] який незрозуміло чого торкався в таких [дивних] формах...
[російською] Але всім стало зрозуміло: щоб вижити...
[російською] І взагалі подальший успіх був пов'язаний з тим,
[російською] що потрібно було відповідати цим новим критеріям.
[російською] В архітектурі, в будь-якому разі, якось косо, криво,
[російською] але цю кон'юнктуру архітектори відчули швидко.
[російською] І багато хто з них уник кулі та Соловків.
[російською] Майже усі успішні харківські архітектори переїхали до Києва.
[російською] Звісно, репресії й там були,
[російською] але не настільки тотальні.
[російською] Тому що український проєкт тут
взагалі згортався у кривавій лазні.
[російською] Окрім цілковитих пристосуванців,
практично ніхто ці жорна не пройшов.
[російською] І потім ця криза довіри, ці всі зради...
[російською] І, власне, потім продовження
у 1940-ві, і ще раз у 1950-ті...
[російською] І після цього радянський світ доживав у цій недовірі.
[російською] І ми в цій недовірі живемо й сьогодні.
[російською] Харків дуже показовий.
[російською] Тут багато модерністської архітектури 1920-30-х,
[російською] яка стоїть поруч з дореволюційною архітектурою епохи модерну.
[російською] І вони вже злилися в одну масу, одну історію.
[російською] І одне з іншим — нерозривне.
[російською] Це все є цілісним міським простором.
[російською] Район, з яким у мене пов'язано чимало різних спогадів.
[російською] Тут і гуртожиток, дорога в інститут була — загалом багато всього.
[російською] На сусідній вулиці, буквально в сусідньому
кварталі, я був свідком демонтажу будівлі.
[російською] Такий одноповерховий, купецький, з великими вікнами.
[російською] Я запитав: «Чи не продасте ви цеглу з цього будинку?».
[російською] Так сталося, що ми домовилися.
[російською] Він називається «Heirloom», тобто «той хто отримав спадщину».
[російською] Його просторова організація пов'язана з тим,
[російською] що цегли було стільки, скільки було.
[російською] Цегла стодесятирічної давності.
[російською] І потім цей принцип «секонд хенду»
ми використали в Театрі на Подолі.
[російською] І там довго полювали за київською старою сторічною цеглою.
[російською] Театр на Подолі був викликом проти фальшивого міста.
[російською] Для мене було відкриттям, що ми
потрапили в інформаційну війну.
[російською] У нас було декілька варіантів,
ми обрали найбільш консервативний.
[російською] І це було щось таке...
[російською] Порівняно з тим, що ми хотіли зробити, хороший був сценарій,
[російською] то це була найбільш консервативна пропозиція.
[російською] Але я безмежно вдячний.
[російською] Вийшло дуже багато важливих текстів.
[російською] І частина дискусій перейшла в дуже серйозне русло.
[російською] У якісь висловлювання, доволі глибокі аналізи...
[російською] Загалом я вдячний, відбулось п'ять-шість хороших рефлексій.
[російською] Які зокрема були...
Харків — студентське місто, такий є стереотип.
Харків і справді студентське місто.
В Харкові навчається 35 % іноземних студентів.
Велика кількість студентів українських. Це справді так.
Але ця молодь їде.
Я сподіваюся, у Харкові буде таке життя, де захочеться залишитись.
Я думаю, що для Харкова — це найважливіша місія.
Люди, які сміливі, які мають можливості,
мають енергію на реалізацію великих проєктів,
вони просто повинні тут залишатись.
[російською] Усе хороше завжди вигадується в кризи.
[російською] 2014 рік остаточно змінив загальну повістку.
[російською] І нам здалося, що зміни можуть з'явитися лише через нових агентів цих змін.
Це конкурс для школярів 9–11 класів,
які роздумують щодо професії.
Можуть себе спробувати, як мислять архітектори,
податися до нас і в результаті конкурсу отримати один із сертифікатів
на навчання в Харківській школі архітектури.
[російською] Окрім навичок подачі такого малювання,
[російською] багато проєктів мають найважливіше в архітектурі — критичне
[російською] мислення, рефлексію на те, що
відбувається навколо, певні цінності.
[російською] Крутим професіоналом можна стати по-справжньому,
[російською] коли навколо конкурентне середовище.
[російською] Якщо ж його немає, то його потрібно створювати
[російською] У фокусі і в центрі нашої школи — це студент,
[російською] його кар'єра, його майбутній шлях,
його вихід у соціальний простір.
[російською] І, мабуть, ще варто згадати один важливий момент:
[російською] це навчання не заради навчання,
[російською] а навчання, яке повинно змінити наші міста.
[російською] Віримо в те, що певне коло осіб — це вже спільнота,
[російською] яка буде розуміти архітектуру, цікавитися архітектурою
[російською] І зможе разом з архітекторами створити таке поле,
[російською] в якому змінюється наше місто.
Якщо ми поглянемо на простір Харкова, то помітимо, що він дуже вітряний.
Дуже мало міських просторів, які щось тримають.
Таке відчуття, коли виходимо на вокзалі, що тебе здуває вітром.
Я думаю, Харків повинен трохи трансформуватися,
переосмислити підхід для того, щоб акумулювати людей ідеї і простори.
[російською] Можу сказати, що в нас також багато змінилося після 2014 року.
[російською] Хоча й не так помітно.
[російською] Все ж таки перемикач не до кінця клацнув,
[російською] але він точно кудись повернув.
[російською] Абсолютно точно нове покоління набирає обертів.
[російською] Раніше просто увійти в це цілком закрите ложе було важко.
[російською] Для нас, для школи це також
важливий момент, значно більше шансів...
[російською] Кватирка туди, у світ, відкрилась.